and he tried to chop my finger
it broke my hand
this is virginia it's not her real name
she's scared her ex-husband is trying to
find and kill her that's why she's
seeking asylum here in the uk
he battered me on with a mallet
she says her husband joined a gang and
started abusing her torturing her
forcing her to be cut that is female
genital mutilation or fgm i didn't want
to undergo the cat so he started
he started beating me up torturing me
cutting me with my knife they forced me
to go
to
to undergo the cat but before then
they tortured me
afterwards she escaped and fled to
england
they are coming from my head and that is
when i decided to go because i knew they
were not joking
virginia has twice had her asylum claim
denied she's now appealed again
to claim asylum you need to show you are
persecuted and you can't get help in
your home country
there seems to be a sort of myth that
asylum is easy to get in this country
it's not it's really hard to get you
really have to prove to prove that a
state is unwilling or unable to help you
it's a very high threshold
the home office says it takes the
well-being of asylum seekers incredibly
seriously and considers sensitively all
the evidence in their claims including
of domestic violence or female genital
mutilation
and it says it's working with countries
around the world to try and prevent
crimes like fgm happening in the first
place
but campaign has worn the rigidity of
the asylum system means women and girls
could still fall through the cracks it's
really important to recognize that
um
our policies don't match our rhetoric in
terms of protecting women and girls from
violence around the world the grounds
for protection under the refugee
convention are very narrow and very
strict and definitely too narrow
behind all the legal complexity this is
a story about a woman a woman like
thousands of others stranded between
fear of the past and hope for an
uncertain future
madeleine ratcliffe sky news